when I was a kid growing up in the Bobby
Fischer era and the 1972 World
Championship I would literally run to
the club and want to be at the
chessboard where all of the members were
around and all of the members were
moving the pieces and analyzing and
saying no no he should go here no no he
should go there and it was a very
wonderful social exchange and I learned
a great deal about chess and World
Championship matches by sharing the
analysis with other members of the club
it was really one of the great
highlights of my growing up in chess and
so I would like to share that with you
by going through a world championship in
those days back in the 70s World
Championship matches were rather regular
but they only came once every three
years so regular but irregular and you
look forward to a world championship
match once every three years it was a
very lengthy cycle as the world champion
would wait for a challenger to be
determined let's get to the game Magnus
opened up with E for again Magnus could
clinch the match with a victory in this
game or he could clinch the match with
two draws he opened up efore and several
times in the match this she had already
defended a Berlin defense so Knight f6
with a counter-attack on the pawn on e4
white could Y could defend this pawn by
defending it with his knight
fending it with d3 or defending it with
this queen it's been considered for the
better part of a hundred years that
white should castle that this is White's
best plan and black says wait a minute
you left a pawn on capture I'm going to
take the pawn do your worst
Knight takes e4 was played d4 was
White's answer so notice by the way from
those of you who were in the first class
how these world champions are playing
first of all all of whites moves have
been geared towards control of the
center as have blacks white is doing
everything in a very timely fashion is
not moving pieces once or twice or
thrice whites King is in safety blacks
King is not in safety at the moment and
why does trying to open the position to
get at blacks King black retreated the
knight this is all considered very
conventional moves or what it called
theory in chess so Knight d6 been played
a lot just let me boldly point out the
obvious black could capture this pawn on
d4 that would give them a material
advantage of two pawns however as we see
if we move our rook to e1 oops the
knight is pinned to the king and after
d5 Knight takes root d4 white has a very
serious initiative he's threatening to
capture twice on c6 he's threatening to
play f2 f3 winning the knight and black
is in serious trouble
so black plays Knight d6 Bishop takes on
takes
Pond takes white recovers the pond that
he sacrificed
9f5 Queen takes da check King takes d8
so we'll stop here for just a moment and
say well you know some very interesting
things have happened the first is that
black has lost the right to castle now
that he's moved his king there's no more
castle so that's not good for for black
white has doubled the pawns on c7 and c6
so blacks pawn structure has been dinged
that's not good for that element the
pawn structure so those are two bad
things that have happened to black he's
had to move his King giving up the right
to castle he's had double pawns on the
Queen side so what does he get in return
he gets the two bishops from the
material point of view from the material
count Black is not ahead in the material
count but grandmasters consider that the
bishops even though the bishops and
Knight are both worth three points each
are a smidgen they're a little bit
better than the Knights so black has the
long term prospect of having the two
bishops okay so then what happened
Bishop d7 this is a very topical
position amongst the world's best
players today this precise position and
almost all the top players enjoy playing
both sides of this Berlin defense one of
the interesting things about chess
openings amongst the really really top
players is how precise you have to play
if you play
a position if you play a defense like
the knight ourf Sicilian if you play a
Greenfeld defense these are very very
sharp defenses
where every single move is vital but you
can't mix up your move order you could
lose the game just by getting your move
order wrong
conversely the Berlin is like one of
those defenses where a lot of the moves
are interchangeable black here has just
played oh he's he's made a lot of moves
Bishop to d7 Bishop to e6 h 697 and it
seems like he just has a large a large
selection a great number of options that
he can make in the game
Vichy played Bishop d7 Vichy in two
games earlier in the match in both games
he moved his king in this penultimate
game he played Bishop d7 and this showed
a little combative Ness that he wasn't
going to he's going to look for a change
over what had previously taken place
night c3h7 h6 sorry I just wanted to
point out that once again black has
played in this position King c8 he's
played b6 he's played c5 and he's played
a5 a lot of these moves are
interchangeable essentially black wants
his King out of the center and he's
going to put his King on see 8b 6
and King to b7 so what order should he
play his pawn and his King it seems to
be a matter of largely a matter of taste
so h 7h 6 b2 b3 now from White's
perspective if we think about White's
future plans for a moment and both
players are constantly doing this
they're constantly looking
for opportunities to get their pieces in
as active squares as possible so this
Bishop on c1 at the moment this diagonal
isn't that great
the g5 squares protected by the pawn the
e3 squares protected by the knight which
leaves d2 and f-4s squares Bishop on f4
makes perfect sense but at a deeper
level what White has is white has a
structural majority he has pawns on e5 f
2 G 2 and H 3 so we say he has a four a
structure of four pawns against the
structure of three pawns on the kingside
so we say that white has a four to three
pawn majority in an ideal world white
would love to make the move G to G for
attacking the knight the knight would go
away we give it a knight the boot and
then white would play f2 F for that
would be illegal of course because the
Knights in the way but we can imagine
that white would really like to have his
pawns here and here then he could use
his majority okay if and this exact
moment we put our Bishop on f4 in a
deeper sense somewhere down the line
we've misplaced our bishop we want to be
able to advance our King side majority
and therefore Magnus played this move b2
b3 what he was seeking to do was to put
his Bishop on a more effective diagonal
King c8
White has his problems black has his
problems black is trying to solve his
problems by putting his bishop in the
pocket so we can imagine black playing
the move b6 and then the black King
coming to b7 it's in the pocket of the
pawns
sometimes you have this imagery of a
billiard table and the hole in the
billiard table the ball drops down into
a net and it's going to called a pocket
and in a chess terminology the King on
v7 would kind of be in the pocket of the
pawns nicely insulated protected Bishop
b2 so with the bishop on b2 what white
is looking for he hopes is that at
certain moment he'll push his pawn
suddenly and unexpectedly and this
Bishop on b2 will roar down the long
diagonal at least that's the plan you
got to have a plan right
c6 c5 this move C 6 C 5 at the time it
was played and I was watching the game
in real time of course was a bit of a
surprise in the old days it wasn't
considered a good idea to play the move
c5 which weakens blacks control of the
d5 square when the knight could hop
there right away
so what players did is they would play
the move b7 b6 preparing to put the King
away rook a1 to d1 now play the move
Knight d7 will understand why in just a
moment the knight drops back the rook
comes over White has a beautiful rooks
developed on the on the central files
the D file in the e-file and only now
does black play the move
c6 c5 because he's preventing the knight
with a white knight on c3 from hopping
into the center because there would just
simply be a trade on his next move black
might play Bishop e6 followed by King d7
by the way this exact thing happened in
the game
between the she Anand who's buying black
against Magnus and Hikaru Nakamura
America's number one and highest-rated
American in the world was playing black
so Vichy obviously has a great deal of
experience but he had played the
unexpected move for me which was c5
when precedent really was for b6 okay
rook d1 b6 rook e1 White has done very
very well he's brought all of his pieces
into the center he's got a harmonious
position he's doubled up his opponents
pawns on the C file and furthermore
although black has the two bishops and
it's an advantage to have the two
bishops this Bishop on f8 really isn't
scaring anybody this Bishop on f8 is
blocked by its own pawns and is at this
moment not very effective Bishop e6 this
was a very fishy
took a very concrete approach in its
preparations for this game this move
Bishop e6 and his idea his follow-up
idea his concept what we're about to see
impressed me a great deal I really like
this move Bishop e6 why am I so
enthusiastic about the move Bishop e6
well in the first place it's a great
block hater the bishop on e6 blockades
blocks this pawn from advancing okay
fair enough no problem
why why should I be so thrilled about
that take away the pawn on e5 just you
know take it away and what do we
discover that with the pawn gone from
ePHI this rook on e 1
has much more greater effect this Bishop
on b2 has much greater range this knight
on f3 could potentially hop to e5
so by blockading that pawn on e5
literally black is making three white
pieces less effective the knight on f3
the rook on e1 and the bishop on b2 are
all less effective because this pawn is
blocking them by blockading the pawn
you're just making sure absolutely sure
that white doesn't get any ideas of
playing ePHI e6 and just sacrificing the
pawn fair enough white says you got your
stick going I've got mine I'll bring my
knight into the center of the board and
this is the concept that I really like
from fishy-fishy played the move g7 g5
from another point of view white might
play the move Knight f4 and take the
bishop if white captures the bishop then
black loses the advantage that he has in
the position of the two bishops and all
that remains are his double pawn so in a
in a sense as it gorgeous is that Knight
is in the center of the board it is also
this idea of Knight f4 and now the move
g7 g5 was played preventing Knight f4
sometimes in chess the cure can be worse
than the disease to prevent the move
Knight AFF for you cured that move you
prevented the move Knight f4 by playing
the move g5 but the move g5 has made the
square f6 a tremendously weak severely
weak square and a great outpost for
white so here the cure might be worse
than the disease c2 c4 but a long
with controlling the f4 square another
great benefit for Vichy is that this
minority of three pawns versus this
majority of four pawns the minority is
doing a very good job at keeping white
spawns at bay white is not able to play
f4 and g4 and f5 and drive blacks pieces
backwards so this pawn g5 is stopping
white from using his majority
similarly white doesn't say c2 c4 white
blocks black has a majority four versus
three on the queenside and black army
white locks up the black majority by
playing c4 king b7 and now white has an
issue to solve first of all white has to
decide what what's this plan what what
is he going to do further from a
harmonic point of view White has kind of
achieved a bit of a maximum for his
pieces the rooks are excellent the
Knights are excellent the bishops are
excellent but okay what are we going to
do for a plan what would you guys do any
suggestions for white
don't all shout out at once now yeah
you suggest the move a to a four very
good suggestion by the way in fact that
happened very concretely let's say a
four a five which in fact happened in
the game now we need a further plan it's
like we play a four he played a five so
what's our further plan
in fact I'm asking you in truth or
fairness or unfair a very difficult
question and in principle when I get
stuck I'm like this as white and I say
okay I'm doing really good but how do i
improve what what move do I make how do
I start looking around the board and
asking my pieces how are they feeling so
I would do this I would consciously do
this I'd ask this guy how you doing I'm
great I'm great I'm great leave me alone
Bishop mm-hmm never felt better
Bishop says I'm feeling as good as I can
the rooks fine so then I come to the
King or the knife how are you doing the
knight on f3 answers truthfully I'm not
sure I think I'm okay but I'm not I
don't have a great deal of room to go to
in fact there might be better squares
for me could you look for a better
square and then I go aha I can improve
the position of my knight I could move
this Knight to this squared D 2 followed
by e4 followed by east f6 my knight
would be much nicer placed in my
opponent's can besides this route Knight
d2 to e4 to f6 I could also play Knight
to h2 Knight to g4 Knight to f6 get to
the same place just by a different route
so
if I were white I would be very
attracted to this idea of moving my
knight to f6 but I'd also ask my king
how about you can you be improved my
King says yeah I could be improved
you could play g2 g3 King g2 and I'm a
little bit more up to board
um and then I talked to my pawns these
pawns man no it's like these guys I've
got to figure out a way of playing g4
and f4 and advancing my pawns
so what Magnus a practice has taught
these players most especially is that
white does want to play the move G to G
for but he doesn't want to do it
prematurely if he plays g4 and drives
the night away sometimes there can be
the counter-attack Age 5 so what white
wants to do is he wants to play g4 and
support the pawn with his king the world
champion played king h2 and will
understand why in a moment a seven a
five by black a two a four so now the
Queen side if you will is locked down
right everything all the action now
moves from the Queen side to the center
as well as the King side the move G to G
4 is basically unpreventable so in
anticipation of being attacked the night
voluntarily moves backwards g4 Knight g6
so the knight moves to a little bit more
flexible squares it the night on g6
controls or attacks if you prefer the h4
as well as the f4 Square King g3 so
again we see this very nice harmony by
the world champion
as he's trying to bring all of this
pieces into the ideal squares where the
pieces will be most effective
now with the King on g3 ideas of
counter-attack with h5 really aren't
going to succeed the pawn on g4 is
well-protected and in fact quite the
opposite now that White's King is on g3
White has ideas of potentially advancing
his h1 okay Bishop e7 at very long last
black Connexus rooks Bishop e7 and now
White says okay I got everything going
that I could possibly get going
this last move Bishop e7 kind of stops
the h4 idea the one this guy's good good
good good good improvement let's improve
this guy 92 black says well both my
rooks need improvement but I can only
improve one of them at a time
let me improve this one yes yes
right very good question very good
question
so the question was after this move
Bishop e7 why shouldn't we just for
example why not take it Knight takes
even Knight would have to recapture and
now we get a position that White has
gotten rid of the opponent's two bishops
advantage but remember that knight on d5
was pretty attractive too right now what
we have is a bishops of opposite color
position bishops of opposite color
middle games are notoriously even a lot
a lot of these games are drawn white
still has a problem how is he going to
make progress at certain moment he's
going to have to play either h4 or f4
it'll take him a while I believe white
still a little bit better yes yes
absolutely so the night is very nice on
e4 let me play a move for example let's
say rook David 8 and again at this point
why could it could very happily Park his
knight on f6 but in terms of using his
majority that is to say in terms of
playing f4 or h4 he's still a long ways
away from it we'll go back just for a
moment to this position so I was
thinking that Knight takes even Knight
takes even h4 very kind of compelling
move to cause an accident or a weakness
on the g5 h6
the problem is H force premature because
after takes takes rook g8 darn it the
bishop on e6 the rook on g8 what blacks
counter play or counter-attack against
the g4 pawn is coming too quickly so why
can do something that's kind of cool
here let's go back to this position for
a moment in the game Magnus has played
Knight d2 for all of the things that we
just looked at how about this as a start
oops excuse me how about this one as a
starter move I like this move by the way
Bishop c1 so here the idea behind the
move Bishop C want after black brings
his rook to the center take the bishop
recaptures take the rook and now h4 okay
so now you're set up very sweetly with
the bishop on c1 and you want to do
damage good damage to the G v h6 pawn
black captures
check you don't want to capture with a
night because of rook g8 as we've seen
so you capture with the king rook d3 now
you notice the pawn on h6 is really weak
if y could just trade rooks then even
though it's a bishops of opposite color
white is for choice so I try to play the
move rook III offering the trade of
rooks the problem was that after rook d1
black isn't interested in trading Bishop
d2 now I'm afraid of rook e1 which would
force the trade of rooks so I'll play
rook b1 and the problem is that because
black has a very active rook it makes up
for his weakness on h6 if we continue
the line for just a few more moves
notice we can't take the pawn quite yet
we have to go King g3 rook d1 and I've
got the weakness on h6 that is
compensation
black has a very active rook so I was
trying to make all of these ideas work
and then I came up with even a better
solution for white so where we've been
looking at capturing the bishop on e7
and then playing h4 well how about this
move Knight f6
this looks pretty decent if black plays
in a typical fashion rook d8h for Bishop
takes pawn takes pawn rook takes rook
takes pawn takes Knight so all of these
moves are typical for this position what
these grandmasters would do the problem
is that in this position I think that
White has a really good advantage like I
would love to play White's position here
because White's King site majority is
much more meaningful than blacks Queen
side majority White's King is more
active and that pawn on h6 is a definite
weakness so I ask myself why didn't
Magnus play Knight f6 with the idea of
the follow up h4 this is a really cool
answer why didn't Magnus play this move
anybody
sir
no he doesn't
yes well exactly it's just that
variation that we showed a moment ago
after the move Knight f6 black is
welcome to bring the rook through the D
file and after h4 White's going to get a
modest advantage but a definitive one as
well there's no question that white is
for choice so why not play the move
Knight f6 the typical move rook d8 is
going to lead to a position of advantage
for white amazingly enough after this
move black has a stunning answer black
has the move I mean talk about a bolt
from the blue
whoa how many of you anticipated that
one me neither
I didn't see that we're coming no way b5
Wow well let's try to understand the
move b5 and why it's so profoundly good
if white captures this way then we play
Bishop takes b3 and thank you very much
the rook on d1 is under attack as is the
pawn on eight four we can stop and we
can say Black has the initiative
initiative the ability to make threats
this position is favorable for black
let's go back and this time let's
capture where the other pond a takes b5
and this is the nice point that the move
a4 undermines White's Queen side
structure so that after we have the move
captures rook captures this pawn on c4
is under attack by both the bishop as
well as the rook white will harm me
white will lose this pawn black will
recapture the pawn and stand better
thanks to this unbelievable
b5 so the so essentially we get a
position like this and black stands very
well in fact after for example takes
takes this King could actually play an
active role in going after the pawn on
d5 so that was why Magnus actually ended
up playing the move Knight d2 I'm sorry
did you have a question yes at after 92
yes
b5 well in this particular case now that
the knight is on D to the pawn on b3 is
protected so that after Knight takes a 7
Knight takes a 7 c4 takes b5 and there's
no Brett you can't capture that pawn
because our knight and a next move is
going to be Knight to c4 so why didn't
this particular case would get to
capture upon for free
92 rook b8 Knight e4 Bishop f8 so black
retains the two bishops but white after
his next move everything is looking from
a visual point of view nice for white
his Knights remember way way long long
time ago black played the move g7 g5 to
stop the night becoming deaf for white
infiltrated f6 square so white took
maximum advantage of the move g5 the
Queen side is locked so in White's mind
he's got the edge
he's got the ideas of playing h4 and f4
and if he could ever illegally or
magically play the move f4f to to f5 in
one go he'd be winning just simply
winning strategically winning so when
the players reached this position I
actually thought that Vichy was in
trouble okay
and to say that I was shocked by the
next move I cannot imagine what Magnus
must have felt when Vichy played the
move b5 whoa what a move and is that b5
I mean that was just a bombshell as a
move that you thought you had been
prevented do you know what that's like
right you think you make a move your
opponent has a threat he's going to move
as Queen to g3 so you move your rook to
g1 to stop the guy from moving as Queen
to g3 the jerk moves his creep in g3
anyway and then you suddenly realize to
your horror that the queen is
invulnerable it's like oh you're really
really shot so this move by black b5 was
not on White's radar white had thought
that he had totally prevented that move
from ever occurring and now it occurs
with this break b5 black is threatening
to undermine White's whole Queen side
structure and create wonderful counter
play for his pieces black army White has
a two ways of capturing let's see in
case of a takes a for takes b5 the same
step that we saw before
a4
rook takes a white structure
specifically the pawn on c4 is cracking
rook c1 Knight f4 bang ideas of knight
d3 are now in the air and already Knight
takes e4 pawn takes f4 King takes f4
rook d2 with the world championship
title on the line and you're leading by
a point you wanted to maybe make a safe
draw with white this is not a safe draw
I mean this is chaos anything can go
wrong here and this is definitely not
what Magnus had in mind the other
capture pardon me let me just go back
for a second there was a another capture
C takes b5 this looks pretty okay
C takes b5 what's wrong with this one
what is black gonna do now what would
you what would you say
ninety-seven is a very very reasonable
move the idea behind 97 of course is
that you want to open up the diagonal
for the bishop on b3 so you can take the
pawn on b3 I beg your pardon the Droid
the problem is is maybe after Knight
takes Bishop takes rook takes rook takes
rook III defends the the b3 pawn and I
think black has okay compensation but
it's not certain 97 is a good move but
black has an even better one all right
nice yeah I really like that move c6 a
great deal BAM
c6 attacking the knight after takes
takes suddenly the knight on d5 you
can't maintain the knight on d5 once the
knight on d5 goes the pawn on b3 goes so
this is just simply very good position
for black black is doing great here so
in this position where literally he shot
like you know like the expression you
know bolt of lightning out a clear blue
sky well that's what the guy just
experienced and believe me uh keeping
your calm keeping your composure when
hit you know like with an unexpected
move is really hard and I give Magnus a
lot of credit he played the best move in
the position Bishop c3 and refrain from
capturing pawns as we know
Magnus won this game anyone the match
and at afterwards Vichy said Magnus was
the deserved winner because he he kept
his nerves and this was a moment that he
was referring to and you really are
wobbly you know Mike Tyson says
everybody gets that everybody has a plan
everybody goes into a fight with a plan
and and then you get hit okay and he
just got hit but he stayed on his feet
and this was this was very very nice
play but I still having said all of that
I still like this game
very much so
Bishop c3 takes takes and let me just go
over here sorry so you can see now king
c6 a very very good move in a very
strange way as we look at blacks King at
first you know you're kind of looking
and you're getting the impression that
that's not a safe King but the more you
look at the King on c6 I beg your pardon
the more you realize that blacks King is
actually perfect
there's not even a piece that can really
check the king the rooks I'm not going
to be able to check the King either on
the b6 or d6 squares the knight is not
going to be able to check the so the
King is actually perfect the knight has
blocked the D file but now by moving the
King to the c6 the B file is open so
blacks pieces are looks are ready to
come to the B file and at this moment I
had the feeling that black was more than
okay that somewhere somehow I don't know
exactly how that that white advantage
has disappeared completely furthermore
if we imagine that at certain moment
white is going to challenge that black
is going to bring a rook to the B file
and white wants to challenge that rook
we can imagine that this knight on d5 no
longer supported by the rook had become
vulnerable and we get ideas like Knight
f4 Knight takes pawn takes King takes
Bishop takes coming into being for black
so the King on c6 is not only
wonderfully secure it's actually
assisting black in attacking the knight
on d5 King f3 so what white starts
thinking is if blacks King comes to
attack this knight on d5 well I can put
my King on e4 with the idea of
supporting the knight on d5 so King f3
and here I think this she made his first
slip of the game
I think he's played really really well
and I just didn't think he needed to
play the move rook d8 ok I was thinking
that
all all this she needed to do when you
look at the position from this she's
point of view to pieces really are not
playing the bishop on f8 and the rook on
a8
I thought that she should play Bishop e7
okay and with a very concrete idea that
I'd like to show let's say king e4 so
sorry an escape pardon me
kingi or with the idea of keeping this
knight protected yeah Bishop takes f6
eat aches f6 if we take on f6 with the
knight then we leave the pawn on c4
unprotected sorry
so Bishop takes f6 eat xf6
Bishop takes d5 check
Bishop takes d5 check C takes d5 King d6
and this position I thought was slightly
better or better simply better for black
the d5 pawn is basically falling that
doesn't mean that it's the game over of
course but if we imagine that black is
simply going to be playing rook e8 check
in the near future where's my how come I
didn't draw a line there we go I check
in the near future followed by Knight
coming to this nice square f4 I thought
black had an initiative so the first
moment after this move b5 King f3 I
thought that this she should have played
the move Bishop e7 yeah okay
so King e for now we get to the critical
or key moment in the game right here
this she probably at this exact moment
he started thinking that if I make a
draw in this game I have to win
tomorrow's white there's no guarantee
I'm going to get an advantage with white
but exactly at this moment he was
probably thinking optimistically that he
stood better and that he has good
chances of winning this position so he
started thinking about risking or
gambling
almost certainly before he went into the
game he's probably thinking all I got to
do is draw today and then I got all you
know put you know my life on the line
tomorrow with the white pieces and hope
for the best but now he's optimistic and
he starts thinking about playing for the
win
had he been in a different set of
circumstance I'm absolutely certain that
the she would have just simply played
rook b3 in a kind of heartbeat advancing
the rook into blacks whites camp and
after for example rupee one rupee eight
rook takes we get a position like this
where black simply has a very good
position thanks to his active rook we
saw an earlier variation with the active
rook instead vichy gets very optimistic
and he plays rook before wow this is
cool how many of you would have played
that move in my case I'm going to say
it's a maybe I would have definitely
considered the move rook before I would
probably have not played it but what if
I said before I made like you know 20
exchange sacrifices or more in my life
18 were unintentional but this one is
cool this one is cool so what's going on
here well we can imagine that once that
rook gets captured we could capture the
rook with the night but after Knight
takes pawn takes this pawn is hanging
this pawn on a forest hanging you're
going to catch at least upon and blacks
going to have a nice pawns coming up the
board in the game Magnus captured with
the bishop now here comes the mistake I
don't think that the exchanged sacrifice
was bad I don't think it was necessary
but here Vichy just kind of went a
gung-ho hog-wild he took with this pawn
at first sight that looks okay I can
understand wanting to take with that
pawn black gets a protected past pawn on
a really beautiful sunny day you might
put your rook here you might put your
king here and you might push the pawn
and then everything's nice on another
different beautiful sunny day by
capturing with a c5 pawn you've opened
up the path for the bishop and the
bishop has a great diagonal had this she
just given the position a bit more
thought I'm absolutely certain he would
have played a takes be sorry a takes b4
and this is a much much superior move by
capturing with the a pawn essentially
black activates his rook okay
a takes b4 now what was I thinking
rook a1 no um a takes before a Holum a
takes before in this position I was
thinking Knight
what did I do wrong sorry I did
something wrong
a takes before not h5 so what's the idea
of 9 h5 the idea of Knight h5 is to play
F 2 F 4 and in case of rook takes a 4
rook a 1 we get a position rook takes a
1 rook takes a 1 Bishop takes check pawn
takes King here
and I think this position is simply
crazy I mean it's very very hard for me
as a chess grandmaster to tell you
what's going on what I see in the
position is too connected passed pawns
and I would be very worried that what
that black will bring out his bishop and
just start pushing these pawns White has
a great rook a great exchange but it's
unclear yes
the next point was what about her me
sorry a takes in this position I have
played Knight h5 why did I play Knight
h5 why didn't I play rook a1 simply
defending the pawn okay well let's see
Bishop to g7 so what has happened after
this move Bishop g7 is basically white
pieces are stuck there's all kinds of
pins going on this night can no longer
move because this pawn is attacked
Bishop takes pawn tonight you won't be
able to take with this night because
this pawn is attacked when the night
comes to f4 Knight takes pawn takes King
takes Bishop takes pawn so even though
White's in a whole
change ahead I actually thought that
this position was objectively fine for
for black
pretty amazing position let's go back
and see what happened in the game in the
game rook before takes takes knight h5
that's where I got the knight h5 idea
from - by the way
following the course of the game
Magnus's idea is as clear as day he
simply wants to play oops
F 2 F 4 okay
King b7 F four G takes f 4 Knight takes
F 4 and now we have it I think a very
key moment here here unfortunately the
the game is marred a little bit by time
trouble the players were down to their
last resources on the clocks and Vichy
has played Knight takes f4 and that
definitely helped quite he should have
played c6 Knight takes g6 takes g6
Knight Bishop Knight Bishop and now in
this position although White has a
material advantage of the exchange we
can see that these two bishops are going
to be able to support this pawn and this
Bishop will have a very nice anchor
square on the d5 square and that
position I prefer white I like White's
position but it definitely is by no
means over
unfortunately for Vichy he slipped once
again and at this moment he captured and
I think he just flat-out underestimated
this recapture with the night I'm pretty
sure his first thought was a white would
have to recapture with the king then
doubtlessly what this she had calculated
was that he would in this in this case
be able to get
two very active bishops and this pawn
oops pardon me this beep on is actually
a force to be reckoned with so I'm sure
this move recapture Knight takes f4 was
an unpleasant one Bishop takes c4 and
now the big difference
rook David seven this rook is entering
blacks camp and white is ready to play
rook c1 and go after this pawn on c7
rook a6 so in order to defend the bishop
from the side Knight d5 with a double
threat first oops excuse me I beg your
pardon
first with the idea of capturing this
pawn and secondly the idea of capturing
this pot block the bishop on c4 is
blocked rook c6 rook takes Bishop
finally comes out but now there's a very
nice combination in the position to wrap
the world championship match up again
from a visual perspective it looks like
blacks chances aren't so bad I mean
somehow everything came to the Queen
side a three versus one majority and on
a very good day this pawn could advance
up the board B 4 B 3 and so forth and so
on supported by two bishops and a rook
but do you guys see the combination
correct
yes precisely very very nice rook takes
e7 check forcing the trade of rooks and
now the point is these two bishops are
lined up beautifully on the C file so
that if King takes c7 rook c1
King c6 again if King takes c7 rook c1
and one of the bishops will fall and
then the pawn on b4 will be easily
contained once we take one of the
bishops the King can drop back and keep
that pawn under lock and key so the best
chance for black was king c6 which was
played knight comes back Knight d5 takes
takes takes and again you know on a
really good day it doesn't look like
it's going to be so bad for black I mean
it's too connected that yes I understand
White has a passed pawn as well but
those are two connected pass pawn and
maybe when we can push them and support
supported by the King and Bishop they
could be very dangerous
Magnus showed impeccable technique he
has it all under control
he advanced his pawn this she passed his
Magnus dropped back with the King at the
moment Magnus is threatening to advance
the pawn so the pawn was blocked and now
white said okay I'll play over here on
the King side with this move h4 and I'll
create another pass pawn but she said
okay let me get my pawn going Magnus
said me to takes tags so now this she
could capture the pawn on b4 on g5 and
just a second
but then after eise Evan Oh actually
that doesn't even I have a stronger move
I simply rook check I apologize yeah
would be a winning check so he didn't
have that option I was about to say
Bishop takes c7 Bishop takes rook takes
is a easy win of king and rook versus
King and it is but rookie five is much
simpler a three go babies go king c3 and
now this she resigned and conceded the
world championship there was one last
trick that he was playing for by the way
if white had played g6 this she had a
two and if g7 b2 and blacks pawns are
very very dangerous so this move King c3
was very precise
if now b2 King b3 and blacks pawns are
blocked and will fall so this was the
world championship game that decided the
world champ the outcome of the World
Chess Championship in Sochi Russia it
was kind of an interesting occasion
because Sochi Russia was the site of
course of the Olympics and the World
Championship match was attended by
Vladimir Putin who was the nominal chief
of the organising committee
Vladimir like many many Russians really
admires chess and chess players so his
government had supported the game and at
the closing ceremony you know they're
rewarding
the championship the laurel wreath and
everything like that and the players
make speeches so it's very very common
in Russia not just Russia but when you
go on stage to accept your prize you
thank the people on stage right if it
happens that you're in st. Louis and the
mayor is on stage and you never met the
mayor of st. Louis or whatnot you still
say mayor thank you so much for you know
coming and and supporting the event and
then whoever else is on stage and thank
you madam and thank you sir and and
stuff like this so Magnus at these
moments in Europe Russia's a bad guy the
West is portraying Russia and the
Ukraine like and Magnus he goes up and
he accepts his award he doesn't mention
President Putin at all you just ignored
it it was like there's this video of the
closing ceremony where Magnus is saying
and I'd like to thank the organizers for
the great job
and I'd like to thank all of my seconds
and my supporters and of course all and
of course all of those chess fans you
know we do it for you if you guys didn't
enjoy chests where there would be no
World Championship so thank you
everybody good bye
and Putin was like like what am I potted
plant it was a very very funny of
closing
Oh